When you think of logic, who comes to mind?
Probably somebody like Sherlock Holmes, who uses his wit and mind to
outsmart his opponents.
Maybe you feel this way when you've had a conversation with somebody with a
different belief system or when you're sharing your faith.
It's as if it's this jockeying back and forth trying to outsmart each other with
logic. Well, this can certainly happen, but technically logic is just a careful and
proper use of reason. Logic is important for Christians so we can arrive at
truthful beliefs ourselves, but it's also important in conversations with other
people so we can help them arrive at truth in a loving manner.
Let me share a story that might help.
some time ago when I was a graduate student studying philosophy I had a memorable
conversation with a professor from an Ivy League school he said to me he goes oh I
think it's great that you're studying philosophy as a Christian maybe you'd want to
study Buddhist philosophy because all religions are true now that struck me as very
odd I thought for a minute wait a minute how could all religions be true when they
contradict on such fundamental teachings about God, the afterlife, and how you get
salvation. So I simply asked him a question.
I said, do you mind if I ask you a question?
How could all religions be true, namely Islam and Christianity?
Muslims say if you believe Jesus is God, you've committed the sin of shirk, and
you're certainly going to hell. I said, Christians say you can't get to heaven
unless you believe Jesus is God.
How can both of these be true? He kind of fumbled around a little bit.
We kept talking. Eventually he looked at me and said, here's the deal.
He said, religion aside, what really is true is cultural relativism.
Therefore, you should be tolerant.
Now stop and think about this. Use your mind, your logic to analyze this claim.
He said he believed in cultural relativism, which says morality and truth depends
upon the culture. But then he turned to me and said, therefore, because
morality is relative, I should be tolerant.
Now do you see the inconsistency?
If morality is relative, he can't turn to me and say I ought to be tolerant because
he's appealing to tolerance as if it's a universal truth claim that everybody should
follow. On the flip side, if he says that everybody should be tolerant, then he
doesn't actually believe that morality is relative because he's appealing to the
universal principle or standard of tolerance.
Friends, people hold a lot of different views about God, religion and morality and
one important thing to do is to listen to their views and draw it out and what we'll
often see is when we do that their views will lead to inconsistency and sometimes
even to logical absurdity.
For example in Matthew 22:41 through 45 Jesus uses the known
logical principle of reductio ad absurdum.
Now that sounds really fancy, but essentially what it means is reducing a position
to absurdity. In this passage in Matthew, Jesus is having a conversation with the
Pharisees and he asks them, who do you think the Messiah is?
Is the Messiah the son of David?
And they say yes, the Messiah is the son of David.
And what Jesus says is meant to draw out their view to show that it leads to
absurdity. Now, how does he do this?
He quotes from Psalms 110:1 in which David, who wrote that psalm, says
that the Messiah is his Lord. And Jesus says, wait a minute, you just said that the
Messiah is the son of David, but now we have David calling the Messiah Lord.
How can that be? Now, what is Jesus' point?
He's saying if you think that the Messiah is merely the son of David, then that
leads to absurdity. But rather it's more reasonable to conclude that yes, the
Messiah is the son of David but he's more than human.
He actually is Lord as David himself said in Psalms 110 verse 1.
In my conversation with an Ivy League professor I was trying to show that he held
two views in contradiction that when drawn to their logical conclusion led to
absurdity. This is exactly what Jesus was doing with the Pharisees.
This is why the Apostle Paul in Ephesians 4 verses 14 through 15 says we are not
to be like children in terms of our thinking, tossed to and fro by different waves
of doctrine. Rather, we are to grow up and be mature in the way we think.
Paul also says in this passage that we are to speak truth in love.
In other words, we are called to speak truth.
We can't compromise truth. We don't speak truth just to win arguments.
We don't speak truth just to prove people wrong.
We do it because we know that it's only truth that can set people free.
And please keep in mind, your conversations will not always go as smoothly as they
seem to go with me and the Ivy League professor.
In fact, more often than not, after a conversation I have with somebody,
I'll step away and go, oh, I should've said this.
Oh, next time, I'll say that. Learning to love God with our minds and use logic is a
life-long process. You're learning some powerful stuff about truth and defending
the faith in this entire study that we're going through.
It's easy to start thinking, great, I'm gonna write this down, I'm gonna go online,
I'm gonna go in person to my parents, my friends, other nonbelievers, and win some
arguments. if that's what you're thinking you're missing the point the point of this
is not to go out and win arguments the point of this is number one to know truth for
ourselves and then second to be able to speak that truth in love to use
reason to use logic to love people that way as people draw closer to you
learn more about your faith they find something genuine and real that is not easily
put out